okay so this side there's cosine
witnessed and come from well more
specifically where does tangent okay so
in order to prove this you can tell just
by the name it's going to have something
to do with circles which is why I asked
you to draw a circle just though we're
going to take advantage of one
particular property of a circle but
rather than just telling it to you and
it's quite intuitively obvious but I
actually gonna prove to you partly
because it will give me opportunity to
do a cool history lesson and partly
because it will give me the opportunity
to show you a kind of proof you almost
never see which is a proof that
contradiction okay um we're used to
proofs by adduction so a deductive
geometry proof is the only kind of proof
that you're very familiar with and
you've been doing for so many years okay
it's simple you start with a true
premise right I know that this is true
and then you work off for that premise
and then you arrive at something else
which is true premise conclusion
everything is true along the way okay a
proof by contradiction works slightly
differently okay it still goes from a
premise to a conclusion premise to a
conclusion kind of right instead of
going from a true premise to a
conclusion it goes from a false premise
something which actually is demonstrably
untrue and then it goes logically in the
same way that a deductive proof goes to
and instead of arriving at a conclusion
you arrive at from the name a
contradiction right you end up at
something which clearly can't be right
which means that well if I went from
here to here by purely logical steps
that all should make sense right and
this can't be true then the problem must
not be the logic in here the problem
must be where I started with okay
there's a very famous proof you might
even remember it for Wyatt root two is a
rational that's basically the only proof
by contradiction that you would even
have you know you're supposed to learn
and last
twelve years of your schooling if you
don't know what it is I can rehearse it
for you afterwards okay
but I want to show you another cool
proof to prove a theorem namely that if
I draw a tangent right to a circle it's
going to be perpendicular to the radius
of the point of contact okay so this is
a this is not a difficult thing to look
at you see it even looks perpendicular
okay how are we going to prove it if
what I want to prove is this that
tangent to a circle is perpendicular to
the radius at the point of contact okay
remembering how a proof by contradiction
is structured how do you think I should
begin yeah okay
well I've got my drawing there right I
want a false premise which I will then
draw out to be untrue the thing that I'm
going to pick out which is wrong is
let's just say if not let's suppose
let's assume he's my premise okay so I'm
gonna need a bit more space here sorry
let's assume that I need some um I need
some labels here that this tension is
not perpendicular to its radius okay I'm
gonna go from that as my premise and
then we're going to make maths explode
okay so we need some labels on this
thing so let's call our tangent PQ okay
let's make that point that point of
contact let's call that a and so what
I'm saying is okay PQ is tangent to the
circle with center oh and that's just by
convention and where it's tangent to the
circle is the point pay so here's my set
up nothing too unusual so far PQ is
tangent that's true so the circle at
Point a right okay so what I'm gonna do
here and I'll put it in another car and
maybe you want to do this or underline
or highlight or something like that this
is gonna be my false premise okay I'm
going
to assume that they are perpendicular
okay that PQ is not perpendicular to UK
with that now this is wrong right this
is wrong but I'm going to take it as if
it is true and then just apply some
logic and see what happens okay now just
on the society you don't need to draw
this but I just want you to have this in
your mind's eye okay if I have a line
right and I've got another line over
here okay and that angle in there is not
a right angle it's not a right angle
okay so like this assumption that
they're not perpendicular okay there
should be some other point what's called
that one date this should be some other
point on this line such that if I do
join it up I will get a right angle does
that make sense
like if that's not a right angle then
somewhere else there ought to be a right
angle it should be a distinct point
where I can make that okay so what I'm
gonna do is I'm going to draw another
point in okay so I'm going to put a
point X on this tangent PQ and I'm gonna
say well if that's not a right angle and
there should be some other point I mean
you couldn't put down here if you laugh
but it's symmetrical so it doesn't
matter okay I'm going to construct a
point X this should be another point X
such that the perpendicularity is true
okay so off of this assumption I should
say therefore there exists another point
right I'm going to call it X such that
it is perpendicular okay now you'll
notice that in constructing Oh X I've
got another point here which is going to
be useful to me I've got this point here
where Oh X intersects with circumference
right now being that I called this area
over here this is another point in
second versus logical it'd be so B is
where this perpendicular line intersects
with the circumference of my circle boy
let's keep going now remember what I am
suggesting my assumption is that this is
not perpendicular right so that means I
can say that there is a novel for
another angle that is right so I'm
saying I'm putting it in red because
it's not true right I'm saying that that
angle is 90 degrees okay so I can then
conclude another thing again logically
holding this together how look at this
triangle linckia óas look at it really
carefully it's very hard because I'm
telling you it's something that it's not
but do your best
since angle o x is equal to 90 degrees I
can right away make a statement about
all the other angles in the Triangle
okay example let's put a triangle over
you okay if I've got a right angle in
one of the corners okay pick a size for
one of the other Rangers pick any size
you like
Latta rhetorical questions give me a
number two sure two degrees okay all
right what's the other angle 90 minus
two which is a Iain okay fine that works
I mean the scales not great but it works
right give me another angle now one in
the corner give me another 145 okay sure
let's call that 45 so what does that
make the other angle 45 okay now we
complete this game for a long time right
but the point is that whatever angles
you come up with and that I didn't work
and infer the other angle okay whatever
angles you come up with they're always
gonna be less than 90 always right
you could pick 80
nine point nine nine nine nine nine
degrees right which would make the other
angle point zero zero very small angle
right but they'll never be more than 90
why not because because think what's the
actual reason don't just told me kazakh
are good the angle sum of a triangle is
180 degrees no more no less
okay so therefore these two angles and
by extension any one of these angles
can't be any bigger than ninety degrees
does that make sense
so since this angle is ninety degrees
then I can say therefore right angle o8x
it must be less than ninety you're happy
with that there's no way it can be even
equal to 90 that's why I don't have the
UM inclusion of the boundary all right
so far so good
so if this is my D and this is less than
19 right I've got this angle angle oh
yes it absolutely must be less than
angle X right I guess another way of
saying this is since this is a right
angle since this is a right angle if you
want to use words for it the other angle
must be acute right the only way to have
an obtuse angle in there isn't if you
can't have a writing all the same time
right so this is a right angle and this
is a cube all the cute angles are less
than right and writing was that by
definition okay now here's a really cool
thing that you might notice about
triangles right if an angle in one side
is smaller than another angle right then
it's corresponding sides must also
preserve that ratio let me write it and
then I'll show you okay Bert is oh it's
the side opposite is oh x2 all right if
the angle is smaller then the side
that's opposite must also be smaller oh
X a so it's opposite sides Oh a okay I
can get that for a man you can draw some
triangles some
sense of this right clearly if an angle
is small right angle is small that's a
small angle there then the side that's
opposite it will also be small okay so
you've got a small angle it's smaller
angle and you'll have a smaller side you
care of me so far I didn't do anything
dramatic this is all just stuff that
triangles do okay now you can start to
see where the contradiction is going to
flow out right
oh X when I constructed it I noticed
that it intersected with the second OB
right so that means that X is really the
sum of two small intervals namely OB b x
yes it's got two small parts to it
right and that's less than Oh a uh-oh
I'm in trouble I'm in trouble because
but om or B by definition are equal
because they're radii they're both on
the circumference right they both go to
the center
so therefore right I can subtract array
right the radius from both sides and I
get this aha
now I've arrived at when I was after
this is a contradiction BX is a leg
right there BX is a leg but simply by
following the rules of geometry and
using them from this assumption I found
a link that is negative okay
this is impossible
okay you can go through I didn't go
through a few steps there right 1 2 3 4
5 6 steps right you can go and dissect
them as much as you like there's no
problem with the 6 steps right there's
no logical holes in there the only place
where there can be a hole is what I
assumed so essentially what I proved is
that there is no other point X outside
of this that can satisfy this because
you end up with a negative link okay and
so that's why a is the only one that can
satisfy